if you just put a bunch of stuff around
you it looks like a design scheme the
real scheme is that I have no clue about
interior design it's time for another
edition of interrogate its grace it's
just my version of a QA but I gave it a
different name I went on my tumblr grace
Helbig at time.com and I asked you guys
to give me some questions for me to
answer because that's how the internet
works you watch someone that you sort of
have an interest in answer a question
that you have little to no interest in
and it makes you know think about death
for a second yeah YouTube what do you
usually do between takes when the camera
is still running
what if hot-air balloons had legs
attached to the bottom of them that just
ran in place while they floated through
the air usually I think about things
like that or just that you guys really
want bloopers and if you think that that
is a blooper then I got you too should
be dating I ship it that was my attempt
at youth relevance
well the nofilter show ever come to the
southeastern US for the month of August
the nofilter show would not be coming to
the southeastern US we will only be
going to Boston DC Austin Los Angeles in
San Francisco however later this fall
there might be some more tour dates
announced and as soon as they are set I
will announce them I'm not going to set
it and forget it I'm going to set it and
alert you I'm going to Drama Camp
starting soon I'm really nervous about
it like I'm going to mess it up so what
can I do to motivate myself please help
this is overall place that you can use
first starting any sort of camp or club
or at school year or any of the things
that involve you having to deal with
social pressure social judgement
socializing but letter self to be open
to success and failure it's gonna happen
one or the other or both try me present
in the moment and try um have fun but
don't have fun getting pregnant
oops how has your day been so far also
when it's coming back it's funny that
you say that I got the sea goose today
if you don't know goose is my dog a
goose is an aggressive hyperactive dog
so she's been at a dog training program
all summer goose is kind of like a one
Directioner as a dog she will go hey
knocks when she's excited about
something and she will go nuts when she
is upset about something so she's
learning to find that middle ground like
you wonder ection errs [ __ ] anyway my
day is great why don't you do any of the
cooking bits anymore I understand the
creative stress of thinking of something
new and appetizing but I just dot dot
why don't you finish your sentences
anymore the beginning of this comment
was so articulate and made me feel
something and then I just I love doing
cooking bits of cooking bits will
continue don't worry I just haven't been
in one place let alone the kitchen place
to make something for you I have ideas
I'll give you one word soup no that's
not even clue I haven't thought of
anything soup could be good I've never
made a soup breakfast soup no that's
just cereal
how do you find time to de-stress
between all of your work commitments
like that what do you usually for
breakfast
it varies you know sometimes I have a
granola bar this morning I had a Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup and a mini Twix other
mornings I usually eat my pride because
I can't remember what happened the night
before what is a prank you would love to
do to someone I would really love to
replace their Gatorade was urine
from the release of your book is there
anything you are really looking forward
to right now I'm super excited by this
idiots book beautiful dumb-dumb my drunk
kitchen the guide to eating drinking and
going with your gut by the London Lee
Hannah Hart putting that it looks so
cool I watched firsthand how to work
really hard on this book and now I know
firsthand how hard it is to work on a
book so I'm just really proud and I'm
excited for her if you haven't already
go to Hannah Hart accomplished book and
prioritize how do I motivate myself to
work out here's a little song that I
like to sing to myself that motivates me
to work out you are peace Shh
you are human turd no one thinks you're
great because your feces from a bottle
it's pretty helpful thoughts on Troye
Sivan song I don't want to give my
thoughts away right now because they
might be coming out later this week I'm
really excited to talk about like all
the racist undertones that's a fun name
for a ska band
racist undertones how does one
understand the subject of adulthood
immaturity asking for a friend
I mean it's okay I'd really do my
stretches that's it for another edition
of interrogate its grace I hope this was
fun for you I didn't hate every second
of it
just some seconds here and there
scattered every time I get to the part
where I should be doing like call to
action like subscribe leave a comment
down below don't forget to follow me on
other social platforms I feel like such
up a tool don't forget to buy your
ticket story no filter show using the
link in the description below also
somehow I got nominated for a Teen
Choice Award I don't know but if you
want you can vote for me at the link in
the description I think it's change
eyesores calm slash vote I don't know
just you know have a great time Gracie's
guide book calm and a heart calm slash
book oh boy